So let's summarize how to compact.
Conceptually, there are 4 steps, though an efficient implementation might combine these into fewer.
First, we're going to run a predicate on each element of the input.
Then we'll create a scan-in array equal in size to the input.
For each element of the input, if the predicate is true, put a 1 into the scan-in array. If it's false, put a 0.
Then we exclusive sum scan the scan in array. The output of this is scatter addresses for compacted array.
Now, for the final step--for each element of the input,
if the predicate is true, then scatter the input element
into the output array, at the address in scan out.
Let's try a little quiz to get some intuition about the run time of compact.
We're going to compare 2 compact operations, and both
are going to compact the list of numbers from 1 to 1 million.
Compact operation a--let's say is divisible by 17--is only going to keep a very few of the input items.
Whereas compact operation b--is not divisible by 31--is going to keep most of the input items.
So for each of the predicate, scan, and scatter faces of the compact operation,
will a run faster, b run faster or will they take the same amount of time?